at the peter boat pub just 10 minutes
from where sir david amis was stabbed to
death the news is still sinking in
when i heard the nose i've got to be
honest with you it actually did make me
feel really emotional and make me cry
because i just think that's
that
you know he was he was a really good
stand up right citizen and he was a
gentleman as well well i was at home and
it was it was really shocking because
this area is supposed to be a really
nice
sort of area where we've got local sort
of families and stuff so uh to have you
know something so bad happen is uh
is sort of quite unnerving and shocking
really it can happen
it's such a cliche that people say that
it can't happen in our area my goodness
me
john lives around the corner from where
the attack happened if there were local
issues
um
i would write to him and um he always
wrote back on them human life is just so
flimsy i think this has happened on our
doorstep
to a guy you know he's just a family man
i don't understand it i just can't get
my head around it
so many here have a story to tell when
freddie needed an operation his father
says his local mp helped the family with
housing everybody you speak to he's
helped in some sort of way
and if he if he couldn't help he'd done
the best that he could do you know
he tried to know that
somebody like that could so easily just
be gone
just you know in the blink of an eye it
is scary it's scary for everybody
close by we meet lorraine on her way to
play the violin at a vigil for her
friend and local mp he was such a nice
guy very personable
um
got to the point where you'd say hello
sir david i'll drop the sir and i heard
it on the news i think that's when
that's hit
you know
so everybody the whole world is
knows about it now and
yeah it's a bit of a shock
the thing you hear again and again
speaking to people is that david amos
was a good constituency mp he was
someone that almost everyone we've
spoken to knew someone that clearly
cared about local matters and someone
who is very visible in the constituency
as night falls this corner of essex
remembers
an mp who this morning was helping his
constituents a national tragedy that for
so many here feels much more personal
ali fortescue sky news
south and west